good morning believe nation today's
message is be authentically you over to
You Charlamagne tha God it's this thing
called the rule of 10 the rule of 10 is
people don't like it
three people are not gonna like it and
for people just gonna be on the fence
about it like they're just gonna kind of
remain neutral and just wait to see what
happens I use that whenever I say
anything in life however I approach
anything like a TV show you know the
radio show for that day or a statement
on me I might make like three people
hungry with it do you people not and
probably just gonna fix about it so you
just have to take all of that into
consideration and that kind of goes into
something my father told me a long time
ago of my father say you never as good
as they say you are and you never bad as
they say you as a fan personally I just
don't care either way like you know I
mean be authentically me the only way
you're gonna truly win is if you're
authentically you that's it that's the
only way you're gonna win everybody else
is taken this is great clip of 50 cent
being on stage and talking about
investments he's making and young
artists who are pitching him new records
and how often he gets people that sounds
exactly like somebody else people send
him in their demos and they sound
exactly like little Wayne and he says
yeah you sound exactly like little Wayne
that's that's crazy if I heard him and I
heard you I couldn't tell the difference
but the world doesn't need another
little Wayne you're never gonna make it
to the big time if you're just a copy of
somebody else it's why I don't worry
about people who copy my stuff and
copied my channel because I'm just
spending time looking in the rearview
mirror trying to play defense instead of
going out and doing more because you're
never gonna out me me and I'm never
gonna out you you and so at the
beginning of your journey it's okay to
copy at the beginning because you're
getting your feet wet you're still
trying to figure out who you are trying
to figure out what style you can bring
to it but somewhere along the line you
have to figure out okay here's what I
stand for here's what I want to add
here's how I'm different and
not just gonna copy somebody else
anymore the goal of this channel is to
learn from all these famous
entrepreneurs to help you to be the best
version of you right I don't need you to
be the best a next Steve Jobs or the
next Howard Schultz be the best you I
want to be the best Evan Carmichael and
I put a piece from all these people to
help me be the best me and I want you to
do the same don't try to be the next
anybody just be the best you that's
where you're going to win the people at
the table are authentically themselves
they may have learned lessons from other
people they may have collaborated with
other people they may have asked
opinions of other people but at the end
of the day they're doing the thing that
is unique to them they aren't checking
their art into what they are making and
if you don't do that you're always gonna
play second third you're always going to
be way down on the list it takes a lot
of guts it takes a lot of courage to be
authentically you and it comes by doing
it with practice the more you do it the
more you take a stance the more you try
to inject a little bit onto something
the more you're gonna start to win then
work it's gonna feel right the more
you're gonna get people on board with
your crusade that's what you're really
gonna win so start being authentically
you so the question that today is I'm
curious what have you added recently
into your business that is authentically
you you added your mark on to it what
did you do that was different
leave it down in the comments below
super curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shout out to Randy Wilson
Randy thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word really
really really means a lot to man and I
hope you're enjoying the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe on
you if we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
festival
Express Oh give me go
how do you come up and radio how'd you
start figure oh my started off as an
intern in 1998 when I was 18 years old
I'm 32 now already he's 115 being around
when I started off as an intern I was 18
so I worked in every aspect of radio
I've worked in the promotion's
department I worked in program and I was
an intern for a year and a half you know
I worked in the 7th radio station I
worked there I've been fired four times
you know what I'm saying so it's like
that's why when I thought William like a
wham came back out there to perform well
for everybody who wasn't at the show
when was a rapper who got booed but he
forced them to let him perform again I
just like your determination like didn't
ever say quit attitude because that's
what you have to have the man I got said
I've been fired four times I could have
quit a long time ago but I don't have no
backup plan I didn't go to college I
don't have a degree you know I don't
have anything else to do but radio and I
used to wanna rap until I realize that
represent it's just it's so many things
that you go through in this game and so
many ends in flow so many ups and downs
but the people that truly keep going
that make it but the reason I made it
because I knew exactly what I wanted
tell me what your vision board looks
like and can you share some of the
things that are on there I have a
traditional vision boy well you know you
would take things that you want and put
them up on poster boy whatever whatever
and that's cool
I read you know I did that when I did
the secret but to me the best vision was
when you write down your long-term and
short-term goals write down everything
that you want to accomplish and keep
those things in your mind because your
mind is what makes them manifest in the
reality like your thoughts really do
become things like I don't have a
college degree or anything like that all
I have is back in 1998 I said I want to
be a super jock I said I want to be one
of the biggest radio personalities on
the planet I said I want to be you know
and that Wendy Williams Tom Joyner Doug
banks
Howard Stern you know Bill O'Reilly Rush
Limbaugh I want to be in that number
you know when they think of charlemagne
I want them to think of me like that and
I want to be my generations that because
all of those guys it's the natural
course of thing that power eventually
fades and weakens all of them it's just
like the NBA of music it was the Magic
Johnson Larry Bird era and it was
michael jordan air lebron james there
that's just the way things are in the
game and i knew that eventually it would
be my time if i wanted that and so I
claimed it so my vision board is a
really just a notebook with everything
that I want in my life they dope I mean
50 actually put out some great records
earlier this year join me out with
Kendrick Lamar and he had another record
the joint with too short I thought was
dope but when people are off you yeah he
got his pocket of fans that'll still
support him but you'll never see 50 cent
selling 10 million records again hell
you're never see 50 Cent's alone million
records again not a one album you might
do it as a single and that's not that's
not a diss to him it's just that's the
way hip hop is nobody cares no no you
know I'm saying like I thought changes
love changes and best friends become
strangers man like it happens all the
time it happens to cycle everybody can't
be jay-z you know cuz but and the reason
jay-z and jay-z but Jamie has been
consistent if you drop the album every
year since 1996